it's the biggest disrupter the diamond
industry has faced we're growing
diamonds that are identical in every way
to a mine stone lab-grown diamonds in
the future of the industry machines are
now growing diamonds in a matter of
weeks for two-thirds of the price but
can they replace the magic of a mind
stone these stones were created by
Nature thousands of years ago love
created diamonds could never take the
place of the real sink could they cause
the 82 billion-dollar diamond jewelry
industry to lose its sparkle you must
travel back in time to witness his birth
sophisticated ads have been making the
case for diamonds for decades De Beers
the world's biggest rough diamond
producer by value linked diamonds with
romance in the late 1940s and dreamt up
the idea of a diamond engagement ring as
an essential display of love the diamond
due to brain power stood two months
salary lasts forever
diamonds are purchased emotionally
people in previous times adorned God's
wisdom so-called queen of diamonds Alisa
mazayef sells gems to the rich and the
Royal the world over and has done for
over half a century for her there's more
to a diamond than its chemical structure
the energy is in the stone itself the
moment your did in your hand you would
feel it it speaks to you the real
diamonds has got the energy which can
never be recreated while sales of
lab-grown diamonds are about two percent
of the industry the market is growing by
over 15% a year they've actually been
around for more than 60 years
recently the process and the product
have been refined california-based
diamond foundry can create a 1 carat
diamond in two weeks the process begins
by taking a seed crystal right here you
can actually see a seed itself this
contains the atomic blueprint that
actually makes the diamonds diamonds the
reactors are then filled with a mixture
of carbon cane and gases and those gases
are electrically separated so of the
carbon atoms themselves bond with the
surface of the sea any gemologist in the
world will put one of our stones under
grading lamp and graded exactly the same
as a mine stone though the difference
can be detected using specialized
equipment in a lab the US Federal Trade
Commission in July 2018 expanded its
definition of a diamond to include
lab-grown stones but mrs. Messiah
doesn't feel threatened love created
diamonds may affect at the lower part of
the market but it will never affect the
real gems
there will be no disruption the very
expensive diamonds are still bought for
investment purposes an investment which
holds its value
now buyers can pick up a lab-grown
diamond for 1/3 less than a mind stone
and this technology improves prices will
drop further big mind stones are
valuable because they are rare but
diamond mining has been linked to
conflict human rights abuses and state
corruption lab-grown diamonds provide an
ethically sourced alternative we're
giving customers the option a product
that is 100% traceable and origin
guaranteed that just hasn't been
possible in the diamond industry before
but until top designers decide to work
with lab-grown stones their potential
will be limited within the luxury market
I would not call an up created diamond
jewelry really I would consider it an
ornament an ornament can be made of silk
it can be made of steel and it can be
made as a love created diamond lab-grown
diamonds need the glamour and romance
associated with mined diamonds if
they're going to survive mine diamonds
and lab-grown diamonds can coexist
peacefully in the market we hope that
lab-grown diamonds growth in the
industry will be a call to action for
the entire industry to clean up their
practices it's a direction the diamond
market is already heading as of January
2019 Tiffany and Co the biggest jeweler
in the world by sales will disclose the
origin of all of its diamonds it could
force a new wave of transparency across
the jewelry world but for the makers of
lab-grown
diamonds the jewelry world is only the
beginning
diamonds can be used in everything from
cutting and grinding to quantum
computing which can drive the true
future of computing it's not the end of
the diamond industry it's the beginning
[Music]